[Music]  in china's weilong valley you can find  2.2 miles of naturally formed hot  springs just follow the yellow calcified  trail  these colorful ponds have formed over a  thousand years by geologic change  causing the limestone to mold and the  crystal clear waters to overflow into  the series of pools below  on either side of this natural wonder  are rugged mountains and forests  from a distance the cream yellow rock of  the hot springs weaves through the  forest standing out as a steaming oasis  the color and shape result in the locals  calling the pools the yellow dragon  wang long valley is also home to the  wenglong monastery and one of its  remaining temples can be found at the  top of the pool's terraces  for many years the area was under the  threat of industrialization  but through local efforts and being a  unesco site the yellow dragon will be  seen in its natural beauty for  generations to come  you